Schalke strauchelt Düsseldorf im Aufschwung. Die 2. Liga bleibt weiterhin spannend. Und wir wollen darüber sprechen mit Thorsten Wiese von Gebrabbel Rot-Weiß und Michael Fischer vom Vierter Flachpass und den Nürnberger Nachrichten. Und jetzt geht's los. Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Langeheil fliegt vorbei, und der Ball ist im Tor! Und Augsburg ist oben! Rossi zu Kurzabwehr, lang genug für Willi Landgraf! Wagner, Martin Wagner!
Und das an's Turno. Markus Kort aus dem Gewühl.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen. Ja, willkommen zurück zur Ligatour zur 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Mein Name ist Eva-Lotta Bohle. Ich freue mich, dass ich euch auch in diesem Jahr 2026 hier wieder als Host begrüßen darf. Ich begrüße euch und meine Gäste zu einer neuen Pickepacken-Folgen. Zu der Liga, die so keinen Verein wirklich verlassen will. Weder nach oben noch nach unten. Es gibt so ein paar Ausnahmen, aber sonst scheint es wieder so, als wollen einfach alle Teams in dieser Liga bleiben. Und damit erstmal welcome back und schon mal ein ganz großes Danke an Michi, der hier sehr spontan eingesprungen ist. Hallo Michi.
Ja, das bin ich. Also ich bin da auch ganz bei Michi. Ich finde tatsächlich, ihr habt euch relativ sinnvoll im Winter verstärkt. Ehrlicherweise, und da wird mich jetzt Anna aus dem All-Star-Team wahrscheinlich auch noch zurechtweisen, wenn ich das jetzt tue, aber gerade in dieser Partie jetzt im Vergleich zu der Transferpolitik von Eintracht Braunschweig, finde ich, dass bei euch– also ich kann da mehr Konzept erkennen. Ihr habt eindeutig identifiziert, uns fehlt ein bisschen Zweitligarefahrung als Mannschaft. Und die habt ihr hinzugefügt. Alle Spieler haben Zweitligarefahrungen, die ihr geholt habt. Für die ist die Liga nicht neu. Sie rochelt ja sogar mit herausragenden Leistungen in der Vergangenheit. Tlalowet hat zumindest letztes Jahr bei Ulm ganz gut performt, jetzt bei Nürnberg natürlich nicht. Das ist vielleicht auch der Transfer, wo ich am ehesten auch noch ein bisschen Skepsis habe. Aber Knoche und Bauer, der– na ja, okay– war bei Kaiserslautern, ich würde ihn jetzt nicht als herausragend letztes Jahr da bezeichnen, sind zumindest mal eine 2. Liga erfahrene Innenverteidigung. Das ist jetzt schon mal eine ganz gute Voraussetzung und gefühlt, das hatte Michael jetzt ja zu Robin Knoche auch gesagt, ist schon ein anderes Kaliber jetzt da hinten drin in der Verteidigung. Darum, ich kann das Konzept dahinter verstehen und dazu kommt natürlich so ein bisschen so die Ruhe. Also wenn ich dann nur ganz kurz auf Braunschweig blicke, da hat man halt Spieler geholt, die irgendwann mal irgendwie vielleicht auch mal drei Einsätze in der 2. Liga hatten, aber nirgendwo so richtig Stammspieler waren oder so. Das ist nämlich zum Beispiel ein Unterschied. Telolovic war zumindest vorher oder Rochelt bei ihren vorherigen Stationen, also nicht den direkten, sondern den vorvorletzten sozusagen, waren irgendwie über längere Zeit mal Stammspieler. Leute wie Opoku oder Alidou, die waren das eigentlich nicht. Auch Ranos hat sich in Lautern nicht durchgesteckt. Wir haben sehr auffällig das Gefühl, dass alle neu zugängende Lautern Vergangenheit haben, genau wie Benjamin Kessel, der sportliche Leiter. Man hat ja einmal bei Braunschweig so komplett die Offensive ausgetauscht. Klar, auch gezwungenermaßen mit Christian Conté. Ich weiß noch nicht, ob wir kurz die Sven-Köhler-Geschichte erwähnen wollen. Aber ich finde, ihr fandt die Transferpolitik bei euch, und das war eigentlich mein Punkt, den ich jetzt vielleicht etwas zu ausführlich gemacht habe, dass es für mich konzeptionell total nachvollziehbar ist. Und das in der Kombination, mein Eindruck von außen ist, ihr habt einen Trainer, der bei euch funktioniert und eigentlich auch ein Umfeld, dass er alles zu wertschätzen weiß und nicht die Nerven verliert, wie jetzt vielleicht bei anderen Vereinen das schon der Fall sein könnte. Und diese Ruhe mit– wir haben jetzt eigentlich auch Qualität dazugeholt, und das hatten wir in der Analyse bei uns, nämlich tatsächlich ja auch zu euch gesagt. Ihr seid weder offensiv noch defensiv wirklich schlecht, wenn man sich rein mal die Zahlenausbeute anschaut. Ihr habt ordentlich Tore geschossen und ihr habt auch nicht so viele kassiert. Das ist schon mal sehr viel wert, kann ich euch sagen. Darum sehe ich Arminia natürlich nicht gerettet. Ihr müsst genauso punkten und wenn jetzt eine Krise kommt, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, dann kann das natürlich auch da eng werden. Aber jetzt hat man ja diesen Sieg geholt, der war bitter nötig, glaube ich auch für die Köpfe. Und ich glaube, jetzt kann das auch wieder ein bisschen besser laufen. Jetzt sind natürlich spannende Partien, zweimal auswärts. Ihr seid gefühlt auswärts nicht so stark.
Sieben Punkte haben wir geholt. Der letzte Sieg war das erste Auswärtsspiel in Kiel.
Also ich fand euch in der Partie bei uns in Düsseldorf nicht sehr torgefährlich. Wir stehen zwar als Fortuna inzwischen auch einfach defensiv besser. Das haben wir auch gestern in Karlsruhe gezeigt. Das zeigen wir noch in Kaiserslautern. Da habt ihr euch wenig Torschancen erspielen lassen, sodass ich schon der Meinung war, nein, ein Tor hätte Amine eigentlich nicht verdient gehabt, auch weil er zwar immer auf die Latte geschossen hat. Aber naja. Und wir hatten dann noch ein paar Torschancen mehr, dass man sagen konnte, ja auch wenn es ein Lucky Punch war, durch individuelle Klasse von einem Stürmer wie Itten, wahrscheinlich war es schon halbwegs fair. Und da habe ich schon gedacht, oh, das könnte schwer werden für Bielefeld, weil er halt so wenig nach vorne ging. Aber das haben mir jetzt die anderen Spiele ja schon eher gezeigt. Und ich glaube, es war sehr wichtig, dass ihr in Dresden nicht verloren habt. Ich glaube, das war auch so jetzt der Punkt, den ihr so mitgenommen habt und vielleicht auch vorher, dass ihr gegen Kiel, wo ja die erste Halbzeit ziemlich unsehend war, dass ihr da auch zurückgekommen seid und ausgeglichen habt. Also ich glaube, es gab in den Spielen vorher so ein paar psychologische Momente, die die Mannschaft jetzt schon in die richtige Richtung gebracht haben. Ja, und gegen Braunschweig jetzt war auch ein– also ich habe das Spiel nicht gesehen, ich war ja selber im Stadion in Karlsruhe gestern, ich habe jetzt nur die Highlights gesehen, ein paar schöne Tore dabei. Aber ich hatte so den Eindruck, ja, beide Mannschaften haben schon gemerkt, worum es in diesem Spiel ging. Und die Tatsache, dass ihr es am Ende vor euch entschieden habt, ich glaube, das kann euch so helfen, wie es Braunschweck möglicherweise in den nächsten Wochen ein bisschen zu schaffen machen könnte. Auch wenn die Woche davor gegen K2 gewonnen hat.
Ganz kurze Ergänzung, Michi, dann darfst du. Ich muss da auch sagen, ich finde es sehr gut, wie das von der Mannschaft, vom Trainer auch aufgefangen wird. Also da wurde auch selber klar gesagt, ja, es war jetzt ein Sechs-Punkte-Spiel und das haben wir gewonnen. Und es folgen jetzt eben noch zwei weitere gegen Magdeburg und gegen Fürth, eben beides Auswärtsspiele. Und gleichzeitig eben auch sagt, ja, also Blick auf die Tabelle bringt gerade gar nichts. Klar fühlt sich es besser an, auf Platz 11 zu stehen nach dem Wochenende, als auf Platz 16, einfach für den Kopf. Aber den auch allen bewusst, also wir wissen ja auch selber, wo wir da gelandet sind. Und ich glaube, man muss wirklich sagen, dieser psychologische Faktor, der wird noch richtig wichtig. Und ich glaube auch, also mich, ich fand das so interessant, dann darfst du sofort. Du hast eben angesprochen bei FÜHRT, eben dieses, was vor diesem Spiel alles stattgefunden hat. Und eigentlich war es ja so ein Schulterschluss. Und von der Fanszene gab es eben vor dem Spiel gestern, gab es vor der Osttribüne, also ausnahmsweise mal eben nicht vor der Süd-, sondern vor der Osttribüne, das, was man als Spieler als Erstes sieht, wenn man eben aus dem Gang kommt, aus dem Kabinentrakt kommt. Vor der Ost stand, glaube ich, mit Kraft und Mut zum Ziel. Wir stehen hinter euch da und da wurde auch nochmal gepusht. Und eben auch nach dem 2-1 ging der Supporter irgendwie weiter. Und du hattest auch das Gefühl, da ist irgendwie was drin. Weil das macht ja auch was mit den Fans, zu wissen, okay, wir sind jetzt noch nicht komplett abgeschrieben nach einem Rückstand. Schön war es nicht. Sagt man trotzdem, wenn du dann irgendwie dabei zugucken kannst, wie so ein Frenkart da einfach mal durchläuft ohne jegliche Gegenwehr. Aber ich hatte wirklich so ein bisschen das Gefühl, es lag irgendwie so ein bisschen was in der Luft und es lag wirklich auch so ein bisschen über dem Stadion, so ein bisschen dieser Endspiel-Vibe, so ein bisschen zu wissen, okay, wir gehen jetzt 1-1 gegen Dresden. Da hat man schon ein gutes Spiel gerade in der zweiten Halbzeit gezeigt. Fast vielleicht so mit der zweiten Halbzeit, würde ich fast sagen, von dem, was ich gesehen habe, mit so eins der besten Auswärtsspiele diese Saison, was natürlich auch viel über die Mannschaft aussagt, aber trotzdem. Und dann jetzt eben da zurückzukommen und zu sagen, Hauptsache, wir verlieren erst mal diese Spiele nicht, gegen diese vier wirklich direkten Konkurrenten da unten drin. Und ich glaube, das macht ganz, ganz viel mit der Psyche. Ich habe gleich noch einen Punkt, aber erst auf Michi.
Ich wollte noch einen Namen einwerfen, der noch gar nicht viel. Robert Ulltrickis. Weil wir hatten ja vorhin auch Spieler, die vielleicht keine Winterzugänge sind, aber ja eigentlich schon Winterzugänge sind. Ist ja auch lange ausgefallen im Kreuzbandriss. Ich habe gerade noch mal geschaut, das war sein viertes Spiel jetzt ja. In vier Spielen jetzt die zwei Tore in diesem und noch mal ein Assist. Also drei Scorer in vier Spielen. Ist jetzt nicht so schlecht, vor allem, wenn man auf der Bank dann ja einen Godowski hat, der ja auch schon acht Tore hat. Also und einen Telalovic, den man ja auch noch hat. Und der in Ulm, wie du schon sagtest, er schon angedeutet hat, dass er in der zweiten Liga auch Tore schießen kann. Also eigentlich hat man für den Abstiegskampf jetzt eine ganz gute Offensive noch dazu mit Rochelt, wenn er funktioniert, und mit Wörl, der ja eigentlich auch jetzt in dem Spiel auch mit seinem Tor gezeigt hat, was er kann, als insofern das ist meine These noch mal.
Kai Wölthor war es.
Ich grätsche noch kurz rein, bevor du sozusagen Bielefeld abschließt. Ich finde, also Ulricis wollte ich eigentlich auch noch erwähnt haben. Der Lette, Ulricis der Lette, das finde ich, das passt wie Hermann der Trabusker. Also eigentlich, das ist doch Arminia Bielefeld.
Er ist und war sauber.
Ja, genau.
Ich wollte dich nicht unterbrechen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du noch was hast.
Nein, nein, alles gut. Ich wollte ihn nur einwerfen und zur Ehre gelangen lassen, weil wenn er hier zwei Tore macht bei einem 3 zu 2 Sieg, dann sollte er auch einmal zumindest angesprochen sein. Ich bin sehr gespannt, den live zu sehen. Den habe ich bislang nicht sehen können live im Stadion.
Es ist, also sagen wir mal so, er hätte noch ein bisschen mehr Ballbehandlung am Fuß, dann würde er in den englischen Premier League Club ihn als Wollte-Mal-Ersatz vielleicht im Sommer kaufen. Die gleiche Statue hat er, aber das sind auch die größten Vergleiche. Ich glaube, man muss einfach sagen, wenn man auch merkt, gestern Ulrikus wurde zum Beispiel von Tömantwerker, da er selber erst seit Sommer da ist oder so, und auch explizit von Marius Wörl und vom Trainer nochmal gelobt. Marius Wörl hat gesagt, wenn man weiß, wie viel er gearbeitet hat an seinem Comeback. Und man muss ja auch sagen, also Ulrikus war ein Winterneuzugang vor einem Jahr. Und hat sich dann, glaube ich, im vierten oder fünften Spiel den Kreuzbandriss zugezogen. Also der hat zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht lange gespielt. Und das ist ehrlich gesagt ein wahnsinnig großes Kompliment an die Mannschaft, dass sie den eben auch so integriert haben und dass er Bock hatte, auch einfach mit dieser Mannschaft wieder zu spielen. Wurde gestern von der Mannschaft eben auch vor die Süd geschubst, so. Und hat dann aber gesagt, nee, nee, das sind schon wir alle so. Und das tut einfach gut. Und auch für Marius Wörl freut es mich. Der hatte auch einen Grinsen einfach im Gesicht, weil der eben auch keine leichte Zeit hatte, gerade weil er ja auch mit Erwartungen nach Bielefeld kam. Dieser hohen Ablösesumme, die man ja im Endeffekt für ihn an Hannover bezahlt hat. Und da weiten waren alle so, ja, das war so ein bisschen der Pokal Marius, der jetzt sowieso besser in 2026 reingekommen ist. Der hat selber auch gesagt, ich brauchte diese Winterpause, um den Kopf ein bisschen freizukriegen. Es waren dann doch alles auch relativ viel in diesem Jahr. Muss man einfach sagen, für ihn im Pokalfinale mit Bielefeld gestanden, dann diese ganze Wechselpose rund um Hannover. Und dann kommt er mit den Erwartungen nach Bielefeld. Das fand ich auch sehr ehrlich. Und ich glaube, und ihr habt es mit der Abwehr abgesprochen, das kann natürlich auch in die falsche Richtung gehen, was mit Maxi Großer und Leon Schneider, jetzt eben zwei Ausstiegspokal-Helden, whatever, das so ein bisschen verdrängt von ihren Posten. Leon Schneider halt einfach mit unglücklichen Auftritten zuletzt, aber vielleicht auch gut, da mal den Druck ein bisschen runterzunehmen. Und im Endeffekt, ja, bedeutet, also, ist ja einfach gut, jetzt die Rotation drin zu haben. Und ich glaube gerade, du hast eben mit Rochelt und Hilaro zwei Leute geholt, die eben, ja, denen das Selbstbewusstsein ein bisschen flöten ging zuletzt. Und da merkst du aber auch, also gerade bei Rochelt, der den Assist zum 1-0 zum Beispiel auch gibt, da ist auf jeden Fall, ich glaube, das klingt immer so merkwürdig, aber wenn gerade ein Team das schafft, in dieser Phase dann doch Leute einzubeziehen und vielleicht wieder auf eine neue Höhe zu bringen, dann ist das, glaube ich, Aminja, weil das haben sie damals mit Grotowski auch gemacht. Also ich plädiere trotzdem dafür. Gali grü an Bielefeld-Fans. Gibt Rochelt doch trotzdem vielleicht noch drei Spiele Zeit. Winterneuzugänge ist so ein Ding, nur weil das bei uns in letzter Zeit, auch wenn der Maxi Bauer enorm gut funktioniert hat, dass der schon so eingebunden ist. Es ist ein Winterneuzugang. Chillt bitte alle mal. Gut, ich würde sagen, das beenden wir auch. Diesen ostwestchilischen Verein, ich habe jetzt oft genug gesagt, was die nächsten Spiele sind. Wie gesagt, wir schauen mal, wo das weiter hingeht. Trotzdem kann man glaube ich sagen, die Probleme, die waren trotzdem ersichtlich gerade vorm Thor. Und jetzt schauen wir auf einen Verein, wo ihr vielleicht auch denkt, hä, warum hat der das jetzt hier reingeschafft? Schlechte Performance. Das ist der SC Paderborn, auch hier Platz 3, I know. 39 Punkte, 33 zu 24 Tore, 12 Siege, 3 Unentschieden und 6 Niederlagen. Vorm Tabelle in den letzten 5 Spielen Platz 8. Das klingt nicht so schlecht, aber man hatte eben 2 Siege, 2 Niederlagen. Man weiß gerade irgendwie nicht so ganz, was man mit dem SCP bekommt. Ja, sie haben am Wochenende 2 zu 1 gegen Nürnberg gewonnen, aber man muss sozusagen im zweiten Spiel hier eben auch in einer Überzahl-Situation, was ihn bestimmt auch ein bisschen in die Karten gespielt hat. Michi, ich starte nochmal kurz bei dir. Generell haben wir natürlich überlegt, warum nehmen wir Pada Born überhaupt hier rein. Findest du denn, also liebe Grüße an Kevin auch, weil der nämlich uns selber, glaube ich, so ein bisschen Pada Born auf die Karte geschrieben hat. Siehst du beim SCP gerade Probleme?
Jetzt wieder weniger nach diesem Spiel, weil es einfach tabellarisch wieder besser ausschaut, weil man zum ersten Mal in der Rückrunde gewonnen hat. Davor ja nur 3 aus 3, also 3 Punkte aus 3 Spielen. Jetzt wieder dieser Sieg wichtig, weil man das oben wieder rangeklettert. Auch, also ich habe wieder meinen Crush getroffen, Laurin Koder, wenn der in Form ist, das ist schon, also wirklich, als ich den live gesehen habe in diesem Spiel auch wieder, und dann, also, er ist einfach ein zu guter Spieler für die Liga. Aber er ist halt als rechter Schiedensspieler, auch der Topscorer des SCP, deswegen kann man das wieder positiv wie negativ sehen. Ich hatte irgendwo auf den Take gelesen, die Offensive, die da am Wochenende, also die Angriffsreihe, ist keine, der ist ein Zweitliga-Aufsteiger, diesen Take kann man auch sehen mit Tiggers und Klaas. Die haben jetzt alle, ich glaube, 3 und 4 Tore, die beiden. Also jetzt weniger als der rechte Schiedensspieler, der ja dann teilweise auch im Verteidigen noch mehr eingebunden ist. Aber vielleicht ist Laurin Kurta auch nicht der Maßstab, weil er halt einfach so extrem gut ist. Aber insgesamt ist es doch trotzdem jetzt stabil. Man hat halt mal eine kleine schwäche Phase gehabt, aber man ist da oben voll mit dabei. Man kann Spiele eigentlich immer eng gestalten. Man sinkt nie unter ein gewisses Level-Up als es ist Cepada Born. Insofern gibt es da viele Zutaten, die dafür sprechen, dass man auch wieder lange mit oben dabei bleibt. Man ist hier auch mittendrin. Man wird jetzt auch mit einer Niederlage da wieder rausrutschen. Insofern, klar, man kann sie mit reinnehmen, weil der Rückrundenauftakt nicht so gut war. Aber sie haben jetzt eben gewonnen gegen den 1. FC Nürnberg. Ja, in Überzahl, wir wissen aber auch alle, dass Überzahl nicht immer das Leichteste ist. Das zu spielen. Leidvolle Erinnerungen habe ich ja auch an diesen Vereinen, den ich enger verfolge in einigen Spielen. Aber ich glaube, die bleiben da sehr, sehr lange oben dabei. Und wir haben sie jetzt halt mit reingenommen, damit wir sie auch dabei haben. Aber in der nächsten Folge sind sie nicht mehr unter den Teams, um die man sich Sorgen machen muss.
Ja. Thorsten, du hast Paderborn ja gesehen. Und vor allem, weil sie eins ihrer Spiele gegen die Fortuna verloren haben. Hier muss man sagen, da war die Fortuna in Überzahl. Das gehört natürlich auch zur Geschichte dazu. Obwohl man da sagen muss, also die letzten, ich glaube, 18 Minuten oder so, gab es da eine gelb-rote Karte. Und wie würdest du denn auf den SCP gucken?
Ja, ich finde, man kann allerdings, wenn wir über Probleme bei Paderborn sprechen, dann kann man sie in den letzten zwei Spielen zumindest jetzt mal exemplarisch ganz gut sehen. Es ist so die Konstanz über 90 Minuten, die fehlt ein bisschen. Wenn man jetzt das Spiel gegen Nürnberg anschaut, ich fand, sie haben sehr stark begonnen und gehen auch ehrlicherweise vollkommen zurecht mit 2 zu 0 in Führung in der Partie. Dann kommt die rote Karte gegen Lubach, wo ich übrigens immer noch der Meinung bin, dass sie ein bisschen hart ist. Ich weiß, die Spieler haben selber, also ich glaube, Jan Reichert, der Torwart von Nürnberg, meinte hinterher, dass der Stutzen von Tigges kaputt sei und darum ging das Ding wohl in Ordnung. Lubach war selbst ein bisschen anderer Meinung. Ich fand jetzt auch, dass der Schuh nicht so hoch war. Müssen aber jetzt auch nicht zu sehr darüber diskutieren. Kann man aber wahrscheinlich ein bisschen. Aber auf jeden Fall bis zu dieser roten Karte lief es eigentlich ganz gut. Danach eigentlich auch noch. Und aus irgendeinem Grund wurden sie aber dann super nervös, als der Lokoschwili das 2-1 gemacht hat. Dann klappte kaum noch was und dann gab es sogar noch eine Riesenschance von Grimaidi dann später fast zum Ausgleich in Unterzahl für den Club. Und da habe ich mich ein bisschen an die Partie bei uns erinnert gefühlt. Da ist nämlich Paderborn nach fünf Minuten in Führung gegangen, nach einer Ecke durch ihren Winterneuzugang, Kennedy Ogpalla. Also so ein bisschen das Stürmerproblem, habt ihr angesprochen, haben sie, glaube ich, versucht damit zu adressieren. Der hatte immerhin sieben Tore jetzt in 18 Hinrundenspiele in Mannheim in der 3. Liga geschossen, gab auch ein bisschen Knatsch. Kann man alles nachlesen mit Kündigungen und sonst was, aber man hat sich geeinigt am Ende auf eine Ablöse und dann war das gut. Und da haben sie also früher diese Führung gemacht und sind dann aber doch recht schnell in so einen Verwaltungsmodus übergegangen, wo ich schon das Gefühl hatte, naja, ich wollte nicht irgendwie mal versuchen, 2 zu 0 zu machen, denn ja, unsere Offensive ist nicht gerade die Angst- und Schreckenverbreitende in der Liga, aber wenn man halt dann so passiv spielt und das wurde in der zweiten Halbzeit noch viel, viel passiver, da muss man halt sich nicht wundern, wenn man dann auch die Gegentore entsprechend kassiert. Und das war so ein bisschen, hat mich das erinnert nach dem 2 zu 1 gegen Nürnberg. Da wurden sie auch auf einmal so ein bisschen passiv. Und ich glaube, das ist so, wenn wir über Probleme bei Pallor und Sprechen und es ist schon Jammern auf hohem Niveau, da sind wir uns glaube ich alle einig, dann, dass sie halt es schaffen müssen, mal 90 Minuten das am Stück hinzubekommen. Sie haben es ja jetzt sogar ohne ihren Trainer geschafft. Der hatte nämlich seine vierte Gelbe in Düsseldorf gesehen. Das war insofern ganz lustig. Die Szene wurde im Kicker-Ticker so beschrieben. Es gab eine Szene, die nach einer Notbremse aussah, gegen Hansen und es ging also um die Frage beim VAR-Check, ist es eine Notbremse oder nicht. Und der Kicker-Ticker schrieb, Kettemann regt sich darüber auf, dass Hansen kein Rot bekommt. Was ich sehr schön fand, die Idee, dass der Trainer möchte, dass sein eigener Spieler vom Platz gestellt wird. Den Schreibfehler haben sie dann später korrigiert. Und dazu dann noch eine andere schöne Formulierung, die ich bei Sky gehört habe. Er war VIP-Wiedervillen.
Klingt wie so nach einer RTL2-Reality-TV-Sendung, ehrlich gesagt. Michi Ergenske.
Genau, das stimmt. Und ganz kurz noch, letzter Punkt. Der ist auch wieder etwas ernst gemeintere. Und auch hier der große Standortvorteil, es herrscht einfach Ruhe. Ich habe gerade die Aupalla-Geschichte im Winter genannt. Bei anderen Vereinen stellt man sich vor, das wäre bei Schalke gewesen, was da in der Presse gewesen wäre, mit der Nummer. Aber auch jetzt der Abgang von Luis Engelns, der ja auch, glaube ich, nicht ganz geräuschlos intern ablief. Es gibt auch ein sehr, sehr schönes Anleihen. Inzwischen gibt es das nicht mehr Social-Media-Video, wo er frei und offen heraus, ohne Formulierungshilfe, mal seine Gefühlswelt für den Wechsel nach Hoffenheim noch mal zum Ausdruck bringt. Da hätte Papa Daniel Fakir vielleicht noch ein bisschen helfen können. Ich will damit also nur sagen, das sind so zwei Beispiele, dass es da zwar hinter den Kulissen auch so ein bisschen, naja kracht es wirklich zu viel, aber so ein bisschen knistert, sagen wir es mal so. Es aber eben so wenig ein Thema nach außen hin ist, dass man eben trotzdem weiter einfach in Ruhe arbeiten kann. Und das ist eben, das haben wir heute schon mal bei Darmstadt herausgehoben, das ist ein Vorteil.
Ich wollte nur noch einwenden, also Luis Engels hätte ich auch gerne eingebracht, aber dass man halt einen Spieler aus dem eigenen Nachwuchs für 3 Millionen Euro jetzt wieder verkauft hat. Also ja, ein bisschen Theater, aber es klingelt halt auch in der Kasse. Und Paderborn ist ja dafür bekannt, Spieler zu entwickeln und weiter zu entwickeln. Das machen sie so gut wie kein anderer. Laurin Kurth, das ist ein anderes Beispiel, den ich gerade genannt habe. Der Kamal aus der Regionalliga, das machen sie auch gerne. Aber jetzt hat man halt ein Eigengewächs für 3 Millionen Euro verkauft, also der finanzielle Invest. Klar, es gibt ein Invest ins NLZ, aber man hat keine Ablöse für diesen Spieler oder ähnliches bezahlt. Insofern, das wird ihnen ja auch wieder weitere Spielräume geben für die nächste Saison, falls es nicht klappt. Und so schaffen sie es halt jedes Jahr wieder, sich da oben festzusetzen, sich weiter zu stabilisieren, sich finanziell auch zu entwickeln. Insofern, ja, das wollte ich nur noch einbringen und Thorsten hat es mir vorweggenommen.
Frech. Ich habe tatsächlich einen Punkt zum SCP. Also, das ist jetzt kein Drohtszenario oder sonst was, aber ich fand das irgendwie so ein bisschen, ja fast, schon ein bisschen metaphorisch für die letzten Saisons, weil wir hatten so oft den SCP, dass er wieder mal am Aufstieg gekratzt hat. Und es war dann immer so die Endphase der Saison, wo man selber sich da wieder rausgekegelt hat. Das lag gar nicht mal daran, weil alle anderen auf einmal so viel besser waren, sondern weil man eben auch unter Quassenjork eben letzte Saison so Phasen hatte in den letzten zwei Jahren, wo man eben nicht so ganz wusste, ja, also wo fällt das denn jetzt ab? Also ist es dann, wir haben es eben als Vorteil bezeichnet, wenn der Druck nicht so da ist, ist es vielleicht hinten raus auch der Nachteil, weil du eben sagst, ja okay, es erwartet ja eh niemand von uns, gerade nicht in dieser Saison. Es ist eine Unbruchssaison mit Ralf Kettemann. Also das darf manchmal vielleicht wirklich Spekulation, aber irgendwie doch die letzte Motivation nicht da ist. Ich meine, man muss auch sagen, die Saisons, die Paderborn in der 1. Liga haben, die haben wir glaube ich alle sehr schnell ehrlich gesagt wieder vergessen, weil sie haben zwar immer mit reingebracht, dass die Spiele durchaus spektakulär waren, aber sie sind eben am Ende der Saison auch meistens relativ sang- und klanglos wieder abgestiegen. Und ich weiß, ich habe das hier schon voll häufig gesagt, aber Paderborn kam ja aus so einer absoluten Berg- und Halffahrt. Also man war ja entweder immer zweiter oder achtzinter und man befindet sich jetzt seit Jahren in dieser Stabilisation und in der zweiten Liga und hat sich immer in diese Top-Teams erarbeitet. Ich würde fast sagen, das ist wie Heidenheim damals. Also irgendwann, dass man dann doch von außen dann doch so leichte Erwartungshaltung hat, ja okay, aber irgendwann muss es ja jetzt auch mal reichen. Also Kader wird vielleicht nicht schlechter. Klar, du hast auch im Trainerstuhl gewechselt, aber das wäre so der einzige Punkt, warum ich sie so auch, warum man irgendwann an den SCP vielleicht auch unfaire Erwartungen hat und vielleicht eben auch, wie gesagt, liebe Grüße an Kevin Bublitz, von dem das eben auch kam, dass man gar nicht mal so zufrieden ist. Gut, ich meine, trotzdem ist es die Klasse, dass man solche Spiele dann positiv beschreitet, aber diese Stabilität, ich glaube, die muss man eben jetzt mal wieder reinkriegen, dass man eben nicht immer diese Hü-Hot-Spieler hat, weil ich weiß, ich wiederhole mich da, aber das kann dir halt im Ende auch so ein bisschen vielleicht die Sicherheit im Endspurt kosten, die man haben möchte, weil also die können mir alles erzählen, was sie wollen, aber auch steigen wollen sie im Endeffekt, glaube ich, alle ganz gerne doch nochmal. Und das werden die Spieler da auch wissen. Gut, ich würde sonst sagen, bevor wir über Teams sprechen mit guter Laune, habe ich noch ein paar Infos und Ankündigungen dabei. Ich verspreche es, es geht ganz schnell. Ihr wisst es, der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbe-, paywall- und sponsor-frei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich durch eure Beiträge. Und wenn ihr mehr dazu wissen wollt, dann schaut gerne mal in den Show Notes vorbei. Der stellvertretende Dank, der geht heute an Tentakel Tom, Fabian W und Nanobot unter Strich BLN. Gehe davon aus, das steht für Berlin, einem Notch-Show. Aber vielen, vielen Dank, dass ihr schon Rasenfunk-SupporterInnen seid. Wenn ihr es werden wollt, wie gesagt, würden wir uns sehr darüber freuen, natürlich meine Gäste, weil ihr finanziert eben auch damit mit, dass die ein bisschen was bekommen. Und eben auch ich als Moderatorin und vielleicht einfach noch mal der net gemeinte Hinweis, zum 1. Januar sind ja die um 3% von Max angekündigt, die Gehälter da quasi noch mal gestiegen. Wenn ihr das vielleicht unterstützen wollt, dann überlegt doch auch jetzt noch vielleicht auch eure eigenen Beträge um 3% zu erhöhen oder sogar um 5, wenn das den Betrag schöner macht. Vielleicht ein bisschen aufrunden. Das freut den Max bestimmt auch. Sonst ist gestern die Super Bowl-Sendung zur Bundesliga der Männer erschienen. Ich habe sie mir heute Morgen schon angehört. Ich kann sie sehr empfehlen, auch weil man einen Max in einer Direktheit erlebt. Das hat man manchmal sonst nicht. Und die absolute, meine Lieblingsstelle ist die Unglaublichkeit, als rauskommt, dass Sven zu diesem Zeitpunkt das erste Mal Luis Dias und Harry Kane live gesehen hat. Das war, glaube ich, mit meinem Highlight, diese Unglaublichkeit dahinter. Das sind wir doch manchmal sehr gefangen in unserer Fußballblase. Und sonst erscheint heute Abend noch die Sendung zur Bundesliga der Frauen. Letzte Woche ist eine Ligatour Europa erschienen. Da könnt ihr auch gerne reinhören. Sonst letzte Woche zwei Schwerpunkte. Das nächste erscheint dann zur RB Leipzig, aber erst nächste Woche. Puh, das habe ich durchgemacht. Und dann kommen wir zu unserem Gute-Laune-Express Fortuna Düsseldorf. Die stehen auf Platz 14. Momentan, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht vertan habe, es ist Platz 13. Perfekt. Ich kann nicht lesen. 24 Punkte.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, 14.
Es sind sieben Siege, drei unentschieden, elf Niederlagen. Man hängt noch so ein bisschen seiner Hinrunde hinterher, glaube ich. Aber die Formkurve, die zeigt ja sowas von nach oben. Man ist in der Formtabelle auf Platz 4 in den letzten vier Spielen. Zwei Siege, eine Niederlage, ein Unentschieden in diesem neuen Jahr. Und Thorsten, also man muss einfach sagen, wir haben an anderer Stelle, beziehungsweise Mark hatte schon ein bisschen über die Winterneuzugänge gesprochen, deshalb wollen wir da, glaube ich, jetzt heute nicht mehr so einen Fokus drauflegen. Aber was hat sich denn seitdem, ja ich würde jetzt einfach mal den Jahreswechsel sagen, verändert, dass die Fortuna unter Markus Anfang endlich, ja nicht nur häufiger, sondern ehrlich gesagt Spiele gewinnt?
Ja, ja tatsächlich muss man die Grenze oder ab wann es besser wurde, muss man ein bisschen früher schon in den Dezember ziehen, würde ich dazu sagen. Es hat ziemlich lange gedauert, bis der Trainerwechsel so ein bisschen gegriffen hat. Das ist jetzt aber auch insofern nicht verwunderlich. Nicht nur wenn du, nein es war jetzt noch kein Disc gegen Markus Anfang, der vielleicht vermutet wird, aber es sind natürlich schon sehr unterschiedliche Typen, übrigens auch mit einer sehr unterschiedlichen Spielidee. Und wenn man sowas, ich sage jetzt mal im offenen Herzen, mitten in der Saison versucht zu ändern, dann kann das halt schon mal eine Weile dauern. Plus on top die Verunsicherung, die natürlich schon herrschte bei diesem Trainerwechsel. Das hat erstmal ja nun wirklich, das weiß ja jeder, gar nicht funktioniert. Und der Tiefpunkt war eigentlich so Ende November erreicht mit dem Auswärtsspiel in Dresden. Das war dann auch der erste Heimsieg für Dresden, da haben wir Aufbauhilfe da entsprechend betrieben. Und dann gab es halt noch diese unsäglichen Geschichten neben dem Platz, also die rassistische Beleidigung gegen Immanuel Iorre, die Relativierung des Ganzen durch Markus Anfanger. Also wirklich viele unschöne Dinge. Das war so der Stimmungstiefpunkt. Und das ist, wie im griechischen Drama, ist der Tiefpunkt meistens auch der Wendepunkt. So, dass dann da die personellen natürlich auch Entscheidungen getroffen wurden, über die habt ihr ja im Rasenfunk auch schon zur Halbserie gesprochen. Und da durfte ich ja auch schon einen kleinen Kommentar zu abgeben. Also dann wurde Klaus Alofs abberufen. Sven Mislintat kam dann im Dezember als neue Person. Ich hatte eben über das Schalke-Spiel schon gesprochen, dass eigentlich unglücklich verloren wurde. Noch viel unglücklicher war die Niederlage 1-0 in Elbersberg, wo man wirklich klar überlegen war und wirklich größte Torchancen nicht genutzt hat und kurz vor Schluss einen selber reinbekommt hat. Selbst der Elbersberger Trainer, Vincent Wagner, hat da hinterher zugegeben, dass es ein verdammt glücklicher Sieg für sie gewesen sei. Und da fing diese Tendenz an und dann gab es das Spiel gegen Fürth. Da hat Michi bestimmt auch eine Meinung zu dieser Partie. Aber da würde ich jetzt sagen, täuscht das Ergebnis darüber hinweg, wie klar der Unterschied in dieser Partie war. Also da fand ich Fürth auch wirklich, wirklich schwach, muss ich sagen. Und da war es einmal mehr unsere Offensivproblematik, dass wir eigentlich nur zwei Tore in dem Spiel geschossen haben. Und am Ende haben wir euch den Elber noch geschenkt, warum auch immer in der Nachspielzeit des Spiels. Aber das hat dann das Ergebnis noch mal ein bisschen verändert. Und da war halt Sven Mislintat da. Und was man sagen muss, was Sven Mislintat reingebracht hat, entgegen, sagen wir mal, der populären Meinung über ihn in der Öffentlichkeit, ob berechtigt oder nicht, ist jetzt an dieser Stelle, kann man das vermutlich nicht klären. Er hat Ruhe reingebracht und nicht Unruhe. Und das ist tatsächlich ein Faktor nach dieser wilden Hinrunde, über die ja auch im Rasenfunk IV gesprochen wurde, dass da einer ist, der natürlich erst mal die Steine ein bisschen gewendet hat. Christian Weber ist ja auch gegangen als Sportdirektor, nicht nur Klaus Alofs etc. Aber sich dann ja auch nach dem Viert-Spiel dafür entschieden hat, zu sagen, nee, Markus Anfang bleibt unser Trainer. Ich habe mit vielen Leuten gesprochen, mit der Mannschaft viel gesprochen und mir die Arbeit selber angeguckt. Und das Spiel gegen Viert war ja auch überzeugend von Fortuna, muss man sagen. Es war am 17. Spieltag unser bestes Heimspiel oder unser bestes Saisonspiel. Das sagt dann auch ein bisschen was aus natürlich über die Hinserie. Und ja, dann ging man so in dieser Konstellation ins Trainingslager. Viele, auch wir, von unserem Podcast haben schon gesagt, es könnte jetzt aber ein Problem sein, wenn nämlich das erste Spiel gegen Bielefeld verloren geht, dann hast du die Trainer-Diskussion sofort wieder da. Also das ist ja erstmal in dem Moment kein Versprechen auf Dauer. Und dann war halt das Trainingslager in Marbella, mein Kollege Andy vom Podcast und ich, wir waren auch dort vor Ort, haben da ja auch einen Podcast mit Eva aufgenommen. Und da konnte man sich halt so die Trainingsarbeit auch mal ein bisschen angucken aus nächster Nähe und auch die Stimmung. Und da muss man schon sagen, man hatte fast den Eindruck bei der Stimmung, dass die Mannschaft irgendwo im Aufstiegskampf ist. Die war wirklich positiv und man hatte jetzt nicht das Gefühl, dass hier überall Grabenkämpfe herrschen und dass sich alle gegenseitig oder dass alle versuchen, das sinkende Schiff sozusagen zu verlassen. Es gibt immer ein paar Ausnahmen. Auch im Trainingslager war nicht alles rosarot, aber man konnte sehen, okay, im Training, das ist, also ich hatte wirklich einen positiven Eindruck von Markus Anfang, sagen wir mal als Coach auf der, also in der klassischen Trainingsarbeit. Da wurden viele Dinge eingeübt, die ich jetzt in den Spielen auch durchaus wiedererkennen kann. Also das würde ich ihm uneingeschränkt auch wirklich auf die Fahne schreiben. Da hat er es jetzt endlich geschafft, einen neuen spielerisch auch besseren Ansatz der Mannschaft, ich wollte gerade einimpfen sagen, beizubringen und hat ein bisschen gedauert. Und das ist ihm also durchaus gelungen, gleichzeitig mit eben, ja man hat es dann geschafft im Trainingslager so eine gewisse Aufbruchsstimmung für die Rückrunde reinzubringen. Ganz klar, ich habe mich mit Sven Mislint auch unterhalten in Spanien und er meinte halt auch, das ist jetzt alles hier nichts wert, wenn wir gegen Bielefeld nicht gewinnen. Wir müssen das jetzt auch in Punkte umdrehen. Darum waren wir alle sehr, sehr– das hast du mir nicht angemerkt an dem Tag– wir waren wirklich alle sehr, sehr angespannt in Düsseldorf, weil halt klar war, nach diesem Spiel gegen Fürth, was auch schon gewonnen werden musste, dass man in dieser Drucksituation nochmal bestehen musste. Und ich glaube, das hat der Mannschaft erstmal geholfen, dass man zwei wirklich, man war zur Erinnerung, wir waren zwischenzeitlich 17. Wir waren einfach, wir mussten diese Spiele gewinnen, um nicht hier schon vornherein in so einer negativen Spirale weiter drin zu sein. Wenn man das als Mannschaft schafft, das meinte ich nämlich auch bei Bielefeld jetzt gegen Braunschweig, das kann Kräfte dann freisetzen. Das Selbstvertrauen wird größer, die Stimmung wird nochmal besser, man geht dann lockerer ran. Klar, dann kam jetzt das zweite Spiel in Hannover. Das hat man verloren, man hat es auch verdient verloren, allerdings gab es auch eine rote Karte für Fortuna, die also auch korrekt war und alles. Und man hat es dann danach durchaus offen halten können, aber Hannover hätte bei besserer Chancenverwertung das Spiel gewinnen können. Und Hannover zeigt dir jetzt auch, dass mit ihnen auch wieder ganz oben zu rechnen ist. Also ich will damit sagen, keine Schande dort zu verlieren. Und wenn man sieht, wie chancenlos Kiel da entsprechend war und die Hütte vollbekommen hat, also ganz so schlimm war es bei uns zum Beispiel da nicht. Aber jetzt kamen halt so die nächsten Spiele und da war natürlich jetzt das Paderborn-Spiel auch nochmal wichtig. Also man merkt einfach dieses Flänzchen Selbstvertrauen, das wächst und gedeiht. Und jetzt war man halt auch in Karlsruhe gestern. Wie ich fand, die bessere Mannschaft hat auch da jetzt den spielerischen Ansatz, man sieht den halt inzwischen. Man hat jetzt zwar nicht über Ballbesitz dominiert, aber es wurde jetzt das System gewechselt, das ist übrigens vor dem Viertelspiel passiert und das ist sicherlich auch ein Teil jetzt für die bessere Kompaktheit. Man spielt also jetzt in einem entweder 3-5-2 oder in einem 3-4-2-1 mit einer Dreierkette, die sehr gut funktioniert. Da ist unter anderem Elias Egoli, unser 2,04 Meter Mann in der Mitte, den kennt man vielleicht noch nicht so gut. Der ist da aber ein wirklich wichtiger Spieler, Innenverteidiger, der groß und kopfballstark ist, bei 2,04 Meter, aber gleichzeitig schnell. Und das ist natürlich ein Profil, was man in der Größe normalerweise nicht hat. Denn machen wir uns nichts vor, die meisten 1,90 Innenverteidiger, haben eher so einen Wendekreis wie ein Schlachtschiff, aber sind da meistens in Laufduellen entsprechend nicht so einsatzfähig. Und dadurch haben wir es jetzt geschafft, eine sowohl kopfballstärke als auch z.B. mit Kenneth Schmidt neben ihm, der ebenfalls ein relativ schneller Innenverteidiger ist, und gleichzeitig nicht langsam Abwehr zu haben. Was, wenn du einen spielerischen Ansatz hast und dein Team jetzt höher steht, wirklich kein Nachteil ist. Weil sonst läufst du halt in diese blöden Kontersituationen. Das heißt, es hat personelle Gründe, die Dinge kommen da zusammen, der spielerische Ansatz funktioniert einfach besser und es kommt das Selbstvertrauen Pöa Pöa. Das klingt jetzt aber alles viel zu rosarot und darum muss ich natürlich auch was in den Wein gießen.
Warte, ganz kurz Thorsten, bevor du das machst, ich frage mal ganz kurz Michi, weil ich habe schon eben den Gesichtsausdruck gesehen, als es kam mit, ja, nach Tiefpunkten wie in der griechischen Tragödie, geht es ja meistens auch wieder bergauf. Ich sah Zweifel in den Augen. Ganz kurz, um dich einmal kurz mit reinzuholen, bevor Thorsten was in den Wein gießt.
Monologisiert, ja.
Du bist natürlich auch eigentlich nicht so ganz daran interessiert, als Begleiter des Fürther Fußballs, dass Vereine wie Düsseldorf sich dann da wieder rauskraxeln, ehrlich gesagt. Vielleicht einfach mal mit so zwei, drei Sätzen. Wie siehst du denn die Düsseldorfer Entwicklung jetzt in 2026?
Also wenn ich an meinen Tabellentipp vor der Saison denke, bin ich sehr daran interessiert, dass Düsseldorf da rauskraxelt. Da würde ich nicht ganz so schlecht ausschauen. Da kommt noch ein weiterer Verein, über den wir auch noch sprechen in dieser Folge, die schon wieder sehr lange geraten ist. Die habe ich da auch sehr weit oben hingetippt. Da sind sie noch ein bisschen weg davon. Insofern, ja, am Ende muss ich mich Thorsten anschließen. Ich habe die Fortuna ja auch live gesehen bei dem Spiel gegen Viertel. Da waren es die Tabellen 17. gegen den Tabellen 15. damals. Da hat aber er gefühlt einen Platz 8 gegen Platz 18 gespielt. Also da war die Fortuna einfach deutlich besser. Da hatten sie, glaube ich, 10 zu 0 Schüsse nach einer halben Stunde und so weiter. Also das war insgesamt ein Auftritt, von dem man dachte, okay, diese Mannschaft wird da unten nicht lange mehr drin sein. Sie ist es jetzt weiterhin. Das liegt aber daran, dass in diesem Jahr keinen Ulmen-Ringsburg dabei sind, die so komplett abgeschlagen sind, also führt so in Ansätze. Aber ansonsten ist es halt extrem eng. Aber diese individuelle Qualität, diese Fortentwicklung, die es dort gibt, die ich in dem Spiel live gesehen habe, die sich jetzt noch weiter fortgesetzt hat, das sind sehr viele Bausteine, die dafür sprechen, dass die Fortuna wahrscheinlich am Ende nicht nur den letzten 3 sein wird, wo sie landet. Das ist, glaube ich, hypothetisch zu sagen. Sie wird nicht da landen, wo ich sie getippt habe. Das wird ein sehr weiter Weg bis dahin. Da müsste schon sehr, sehr vieles gut laufen und das Diamantenauge vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr finden als Diamanten. Aber ich bin auch bei der Fortuna guter Dinge. Und irgendwann werden die Mannschaften halt weniger, bei denen ich glaube, dass sie da noch hinter Föhr trutschen können. Aber das ist wieder ein anderes Thema.
Thorsten, bevor du zu deinem– oder ich frage das vielleicht mal so. Die nächsten Spiele sind zu Hause gegen Münster und auswärts in Darmstadt. Was denn vielleicht an der aktuellen Situation sagt denn bei dir noch? Also so ganz rosarot ist es doch noch nicht alles.
Naja, zum einen, ich kann ja auch die Tabelle lesen. Es ist ja einfach eine Tabellenkonstellation. Wenn du jetzt einfach mal zwei Spiele verlierst und sowas, kann ja einfach in der 2. Liga immer passieren. Dann kannst du halt auch auf Platz 17 wieder stehen. Und dann hast du halt auch wieder eine Druckkulisse. Und dann kann es auch vielleicht wieder Diskussionen in Richtung Trainer geben, die jetzt zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt einfach kontraproduktiv sind. Im Moment geht es einfach darum, ruhig zu arbeiten, ob man jetzt von Markus Anfang komplett überzeugt ist oder nicht. Aber Ruhe hilft eindeutig mehr als Diskussionen gerade, was dieses Thema betrifft. Aber es gibt natürlich auch noch andere Gründe. Und das ist das Wasser, das ich in den Wein gießen wollte. Denn die Probleme, die Fortuna in der Hinserie hatte, die sind jetzt nicht aus der Welt auf einmal. Also es hat sich natürlich was spielerisch gebessert. Aber die Offensive bleibt das Sorgenkind. Wenn wir uns das anschauen. Wir sind extremst abhängig da von Cedric Itten, der glücklicherweise dank seiner Qualität, und den kennt Michael ja auch noch ganz gut, aus dem halben Jahr in der Bundesliga, glaube ich, bei Fürth, der als Einfacher schafft, uns in vielen Spielen als Zielstürmer oder dann auch gegen Bielefeld in der Schlussphase so eine Ecke reinzuköpfen. Er ist einfach der Unterschiedsspieler, was die Offensive betrifft. Wenn man aber schaut, er hat nahezu die Hälfte unserer Tore geschossen. Das sind sowieso nicht viele, sind immer noch die wenigsten. Wir haben die 20 jetzt geknackt. So, es geht jetzt los, Freunde. Aber das ist halt tatsächlich noch ein großes Problem, dass die Mannschaft insgesamt nicht genug Torgefahr entwickelt. Da kann ich auch Eva an die Partie gegen Bielefeld erinnert. Die hat nämlich sehr schön zusammengefasst, wo die Probleme liegen, aber eigentlich auch gegen Fürth. Wir haben aber gegen Bielefeld, weil der erste Teil etwas evidenter. Wir haben halt das Problem, dass wir entweder zwar gefällig kombinieren, aber gar nicht erst so in den Strafraum so reinkommen für Chancen. Das war die erste Halbzeit gegen Bielefeld. Oder wir haben die Chancen, zweite Halbzeit gegen Bielefeld oder das Spiel gegen Fürth, und wir vergeben viel zu viele davon. Und das war selbst gestern in Karlsruhe so ein bisschen der Fall. In der ersten Halbzeit war es auch ganz wenig Szenen im Tor, aber wir haben Karlsruhe gut von unserem eigenen Tor weggehalten. Das gelingt uns insgesamt, wenn wir jetzt Hannover das Spiel mal ein bisschen ausklammern, aber selbst da ehrlicherweise nach dem Rückstand. Das gelingt uns inzwischen sehr, sehr gut, die Gegner vom eigenen Tor fernzuhalten. Wir haben aber Phasen im Spiel drin, wo wir selber nicht torgefährlich werden und die sind noch zu lang. Und wenn wir torgefährlich werden, dann gibt es neben ittenwenig Spieler, die Tore machen. Das wurde jetzt allerdings adressiert. Ein bisschen Bogen muss ich noch zu Transfers ziehen, die nämlich passiert sind, nachdem die letzte Folge veröffentlicht wurde. Also über Tanaka habt ihr schon gesprochen. Der agiert auch nach wie vor wirklich ganz, ganz hervorragend. Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Mosaikstein. Wer den einmal live sieht, der hat keine Fragen mehr, warum Tanaka uns gerade weiterhilft im defensiven Mittelfeld. Und jetzt hat aber Sven Misslindt, hat ja auch noch, wir hatten Jordi Paulina geholt. Ich glaube, das war jetzt nicht ein großes Thema. Er ist auch noch angeschlagen, war jetzt auch am Wochenende wieder nicht im Kader. Ich glaube, krankheitsbedingt. Der hat noch keine Rolle gespielt. Stürmer von der 2. Mannschaft von Borussia Dortmund aus Curaçao, der noch WM-Chancen hat. Es könnte übrigens sein, dass Curaçao mit einem Fortunasturm antritt, beim Spiel gegen Deutschland, bei der Weltmeisterschaft. Denn Charlison Benchop, den ja vielleicht einige noch kennen, aus der 2. Liga, der ja auch eine Fortuna-Vergangenheit hatte, spielt inzwischen für die 2. Mannschaft von Fortuna, 36 Jahre alt, ist auch noch Nationalspieler von Curaçao. Und es könnte sein, dass Paulina und Benchop bei der WM dann entsprechend antreten. Das ist so ein kleiner Traum bei den Fortuna-Fans. Und man hat halt erkannt, er ist jetzt nicht so ein direkter Ersatz für Cedric Itten, sondern gerade wenn wir in 3-5-2 mit zwei Stürmern spielen, das ist vielleicht noch ein zweiten Stürmer, der nicht so diesen klassischen Mittelstürmer-Prototyp, auch wenn Paulina 1.91 ist, entspricht, sondern so ein bisschen um ihn herumspielen kann. Das war auch mehr so seine Rolle bei Borussia Dortmund 2. Und das Gleiche gilt dann vielleicht noch sehr viel mehr. Und das ist jetzt sozusagen so ein Soforthilfen-Leihe, auch ohne Kaufoption, mit Marin Ljubicic, den wir von Union Berlin jetzt ausgeliehen haben. Ein eher spielerischer Stürmer, anderer Typ als Itten, wo man sich aber, ich glaube, wenn man sich so diese Kombis anguckt, also wir reden vielleicht noch über Bochum, aber Hoffmann jetzt und Marshal ist auch so ein Sturmduo, das sehr unterschiedliche Eigenschaften hat und sich dadurch relativ gut ergänzt. Und das ist die Idee hinter diesem Transfer. Ljubicic ist allerdings angeschlagen gekommen, hat jetzt die letzten zwei Wochen noch nicht trainieren können. Die Woche ist jetzt kurz, Münsterspiel ist schon am Freitag, darum würde ich diese Woche noch nicht mit ihm rechnen. Aber auf Sicht ist da also auch personell und gerade, also siebe ich das Wasser wieder raus aus dem Wein, hört ihr ja jetzt gerade, also da ist auf Sicht vielleicht noch die Chance, dass wir da auch ein bisschen was machen, dadurch, dass wir da auch personell jetzt noch ein bisschen was getan haben, ohne dass das zum Tragen gekommen ist. Und ich höre auch gleich auf, keine Sorge. Ein kleiner Shoutout, den möchte ich jetzt aus der Karlsruhe-Partie noch an Christopher Lenz tatsächlich rausgeben.
Den hatte ich auch noch auf der Liste.
Genau, Christopher Lenz. Ja, Christopher Lenz spielt bei Fortuna Düsseldorf. Und zwar schon seit Sommer. Nur das Geheimnis ist, er spielte halt nicht. Und zwar nicht leistungsbedingt, sondern verletzungsbedingt. Er hatte ja die letzten zwei Jahre sowohl bei Leipzig als auch Hoffenheim, war er mehr oder weniger komplett verletzt ausgefallen. Es gab dann im Sommer den Gamble, diesen Spieler zu holen, wo viele inklusive uns gesagt haben, also mit der verletzten Historie und unserem Track-Record auf der links-verteidiger Position, das kann doch nur schiefgehen. Und genau so war es in der Hinrunde, er war praktisch die komplette Hin-Serie. Verletzt ist aber jetzt seit dem Trainingslager, das er vollkommen bestritten hat, wieder herangeführt. Es hat jetzt ein paar Wochen gedauert über Einwechslungen und jetzt gab es den ersten Startelf-Einsatz, er hat gleich das Tor von Itten entsprechend vorbereitet. Und das ist ein bisschen nicht nur Routine, sondern vor allem auch Kommunikation auf dem Platz. Ich habe den Mann im Trainingslager gesehen, das ist Radio Lenz, das ist der neue Sender. Der Mann redet wirklich sehr, sehr viel. Sind die anderen auch manchmal von genervt? Das konnte man bei einem ganz sympathischen, also es war jetzt kein ernster Disput, aber sie haben sehr erregt diskutiert zwischen Muslia und Imen Karlsruhe, konnte man sehr gut einmal sehen bei einer Szene. Und das fehlt dieser Mannschaft, die ist ein bisschen ruhig, das fand ich auch evident in den Trainings. Da wird nicht so viel gesprochen, ist ja auch immer so eine Kommunikationsfrage, wie Ella Susi, der kein Deutsch oder nur bedingt Englisch spricht, und dann Tanaka, wie sprechen die alle miteinander auf dem Feld, ist nicht immer so einfach. Und ich glaube, so ein Spieler ist da durchaus hilfreich. Und ich glaube, auch das wird uns noch ein bisschen mehr was bringen, denn wir haben eigentlich einen Zielspieler für sehr gute Flanken in der Mitte mit Itten. Und jetzt haben wir auch einen Flankenspieler, der die vielleicht bringen könnte. Und das war dann auch ein Grund, warum man letztendlich da auch keine Außenbahnspieler mehr jetzt geholt hat, weil nämlich auch Weiger Lündal endlich wieder fit ist auf der rechten Seite. Also ich glaube, ja, das wird besser. Die Probleme sind aber immer noch da. Die kann man noch erkennen. Hätten wir eine bessere Chancenverwertung, hätten wir auch in Karlsruhe gewonnen. Ich habe jetzt gar keine Lust mehr. Und weil die Zeit fortgeschritten ist, über den Ausgleich von Karlsruhe und mögliche VAR-Eingriffe da zu reden, kann sich ja jeder mal angucken. Wurde teilweise nicht so breit besprochen, aber ich fand das Tor ehrlicherweise irregulär. Und ich fand, das lag eine aktive Abseits-Stellung vor. Aber müssen wir an dieser Stelle jetzt hier nicht aufklären. Aber grundsätzlich ist man auf dem Weg. Das Heimspiel gegen Münster wird jetzt sicherlich ein wichtiges. Aber ich bin auch zuversichtlich, auch wenn ich mir Münster so in den letzten Wochen anschaue, dass wir das vielleicht auch vor uns entscheiden können. Das kann noch mal wichtig sein. In Darmstadt werden die Früchte hochhängen, aber manchmal ist das ja auch nicht so verkehrt. Mit so einer Ausgangsposition. Danach kommt Bochum, Nürnberg. Also es sind alles wichtige Duelle. Aber die Mannschaft hat jetzt gezeigt, dass sie in wichtigen Duellen auch mental der Situation gewachsen ist. Sodass ich jetzt nicht mehr von großen tabellarchischen Sprühen ausgehe, weil ich sehe jetzt nicht, dass wir noch auf Platz 6 landen. Aber ich glaube schon, dass wir uns qua unserer Qualität da sukzessive entfernen können. Und natürlich ist das auch immer ein bisschen Hoffnung.
Ja, sind wir mal gespannt, was wir da von der Fortuna noch erwarten können. Aber wir haben ja noch zwei Vereine, durch die können wir jetzt ein bisschen flotter auch durchgehen. Und das ist zum einen Hannover 96, Platz 5, 38 Punkte, 38 zu 28 Tore, 1. Siege, 5 Unentschieden und 5 Niederlagen. Und sie sind in der Formtabelle in den letzten vier Spielen auf Platz 1. 3 Siege, 1 Niederlage. Die Niederlage, das war das ganz zu Beginn dieser Sendung. Oh jees, erinnern sich vielleicht noch die 1 zu 3 Niederlage in Kaiserslautern. Aber danach gab es eben 3 Siege gegen Fortuna, gegen Magdeburg und gegen Kiel. Es gab einen Umbrauch in der Winterpause, das ganz kurz noch dazu. Wir haben vor der, also im hinrundenden Fazit haben wir darüber noch spekuliert, weil es eben schon im Raum stand, dass Markus Mann Hannover 96 verlassen wird. Jörg Schmatke hat den Posten übernommen. Ich sag mal so, bei den Hannover-Fans, die ich kenne, wurde das jetzt auch nicht mit der größten Überzeugung angenommen. Weil Jörg Schmatke ist halt Jörg Schmatke, aber er hat direkt die Arbeit aufgenommen. Thorassons Saat und Weißhaupt sind die namenhaftesten Neuzugänge. Das wurde aber eben, also generell gerade auch so Weißhaupt und Saat, das wurde in der letzten Folge schon besprochen, deshalb würde ich da tatsächlich auch so ein bisschen sagen, okay, schieben wir hier jetzt mal ein bisschen zur Seite. Michi, man muss glaube ich sagen, Hannover 96 macht endlich wieder die Tore, die sie zuletzt eben nicht gemacht hat. Also es ist wieder die zweitbeste Offensive der Liga. Man hat die meisten Großchancen, aber auch die meisten vergebenden Großchancen, also 88 zu 59, das ist schon deutlich sehbar. Aber man muss eben sagen, gerade mit klar weiterhin Benjamin Kelmer, bester Torschützer inzwischen der Liga, man ist wieder, man greift endlich wieder oben an, könnte man sagen.
Ja, und das ist ja auch vollkommen zu Recht, du hast die Zeilen jetzt angesprochen. Man kann aber auch dann über die noch gar nicht so oft genannten Expected Goals sprechen. Laut Fortbaup hat man 46,9, das sind 47 Tore, die man sich statistisch erspielt hat und man hat erst 38 daraus gemacht. Also wenn man von der berühmten Regression zur Mitte ausgeht, damit die auch mal in dieser Folge genannt ist, dann wird man noch viel Spaß an Hannover 96 haben und vor allem werden die Fans dort sehr viel Spaß haben. Und auch das ist eine Mannschaft, ich habe es vorhin ein bisschen schon gespoilert, die dann auch dem FC Schalke da oben gefährlich werden kann, wenn sie nämlich mit dieser offensiven Qualität so weiter macht. Es gab ja den Anfang der Saison, wo alle schon dachten, okay, die marschieren da komplett durch und am Ende steigen sie mit 102 Punkten auf. Das hat nicht ganz geklappt, aber sie nähern sich dem Ganzen jetzt wieder zumindest ein bisschen an mit diesen Siegen, die sie jetzt hatten oder geholt haben. Ja, und wenn man sich so viele Torchancen und Großchancen und so weiter rausspielt, ja, da kann man den Wasser in den Wein gießen und sagen, sie vergeben die, aber sie spielen sie sich heraus. Und mit der individuellen Qualität, die sie jetzt auch mit Saad nochmal dazu gewonnen haben, man geht auch so ganz verständlich drüber. Jokota, der war letztes Jahr bei Kaiserslautern eigentlich der beste Spieler dieser Mannschaft. Der spielt jetzt halt in Hannover. Mir hat auch ein Viertel verantwortlich einmal gesagt, sie wollen gar nicht wissen, wie viel die Leihgebühr für Elia Saad, was Hannover da leisten kann, finanziell um so einen Spieler mal zu holen. Insofern, ja, es läuft sehr vieles, sehr gut. Aber es hat auch Hannover 96, die da auch jedes Jahr sehr viel investieren. Also kann man fast schon auch erwarten, dass es gut läuft. Also das muss man schon auch immer dazu sagen. Aber sie machen gerade sehr viel Spaß. Christian Titz ist ja bekannt für schönen Fußball. Nicht immer dafür, dass es am Ende dann dazu führt, dass man aufsteigt. Aber zumindest sind sie jetzt wieder komplett oben damit dran. Und in der Form, in der sie sind, mit Kählmann hast du angesprochen, zwölf Tore. Also eins fehlt sie noch, dann hat auch Ebn Talib verdrängt. Das sollte er noch schaffen im Rest der Saison, weil Ebn Talib immer viele 2. Liga-Tore schießen wird in den nächsten Monaten. Würde ich jetzt mal so tippen. Und dann würde ich davon ausgehen, dass Hannover 96 da aber ganz lange ein ganz großes und lautes Wörtchen mitreden wird um den Aufstieg, weil einfach zu vieles zu gut läuft, damit man anderer Meinung sein könnte.
Ja, da will ich auf jeden Fall mitgehen. Und ich glaube, also ich weiß so die Stimmung bei Hannover-Fans, die war so gerade in der Winterpause, die war nicht so sonderlich gut, kurz. Also weil man hatte dieses Spiel gegen Bochum, wo eigentlich niemand so richtig weiß, warum gewinnen wir das eigentlich nicht. Dann hattest du die Niederlage gegen Nürnberg, die haben wir ja auch besprochen, wo man eigentlich sagen muss, also wie man sich selber zwei Tore so reinlegen kann, das ist eigentlich unfassbar. Und dann startest du eigentlich in 2026 und Christ spät eben diese Gegentore gegen Innskals, das Lautern, wo man eigentlich auch genauso sagen kann, ist jetzt eigentlich kein 3-1-Spiel, wenn du dir das angeguckt hast. Und dann, wo ich glaube, bei vielen Hannover-Fans irgendwie so ein bisschen ansprang, so okay, also was ist hier jetzt los? Aber diesen Turnaround geschafft zu haben und ich weiß, ihr könnt meinetwegen, ich kann auch 5 Euro ins Phrasenschein zahlen für meine eigenen Phrasen, aber es ist einfach so, du kommst in dieser Liga nur durch Kontinuität. Und also das kann in beide Richtungen gehen, wenn du kontinuierlich scheiße bist, sorry, aber dann mich die Hände hoch, wenn alle dies nur hören und ich sehen kann, dann wird es halt irgendwann schwer, weil du dich da, also dann musst du da schon wirklich einen großen Aufwand betreiben, da wieder rauszukommen. Aber wenn du es andersherum schaffst, vielleicht aus so einer Schwächerphase wieder rauszukommen und dann eben direkt zu sagen, okay, wir gewinnen jetzt nicht nur ein Spiel, sondern wir gewinnen jetzt auch wirklich die drei Spiele hintereinander und dann zu sagen, hey, wir haben das in der Hinrunde doch schon geschafft. Also, to be fair, man gewinnt jetzt gerade die Spiele, die man auch in der Hinrunde gewonnen hat. Michi, du hast es eben angesprochen. Also, wir müssen dann sicherlich nochmal gucken, wann dieser Cut kam, wann das eben war, was passiert in den Spielen gegen Dresden, glaube ich, und so war das, wo man zwischendurch sagen konnte, so was war das denn jetzt eigentlich. Also, ich glaube, das wird so ein bisschen der Punkt, wo man mal wieder drauf gucken muss, aber man muss endlich sagen, wirklich offensiv ist man endlich wieder da und kann auch sagen, in Hannover ist fantastische Laune wieder, der Hype-Train. Er rollt wieder und man muss ja auch sagen, also für Hannover-Verhältnisse ist dieser Wechsel auf der Geschäftsführerposition ja auch verhältnismäßig. Vielleicht lag es an Weihnachten, man weiß es nicht so genau. Ruhigera verlaufen, also das hätte ja auch richtig in die Hose gehen können, weil ich erinnere nochmal um das ganze Drama mit EV und 50 plus eins und Martin Kind und Weisungsbefundnis und so. Also das wird weiterhin auch wirklich spannend, weil wir wissen alle, dass da noch einfach ein Urteil aussteht vom Kartellamt, was wir dann noch bekommen von der DFL, aber erst mal da. Man hätte schlechter treffen können, so rund um Thorsten.
Ja, ich wollte dazu noch ergänzen, weil ich nämlich genau nach der Auftaktniederlage und vor unserem Spiel in einem Hannover-Podcast Vorwärts nach weit, liebe Grüße, an dieser Stelle zu Gast war. Und die Stimmungslage da entsprach, also entsprechend der, die du gerade genannt hattest, da ging es schon ein bisschen um die Frage, ob Jörg Schmatke, denn das darf man nicht vergessen, Titz ist ja nicht sein Trainer, ob der, wenn das jetzt gegen Düsseldorf schief geht, da nicht sogar schon die Reißleine ziehen könnte bei Christian Titz. Und es ist natürlich jetzt anders gekommen. Und um das bei Michi zu ergänzen, also Jokota war der entscheidende Spieler gegen uns und auch jetzt sonst, würde ich sagen, einer der insgesamt herausragenden Spieler dieser Rückrunde bisher, der zeigt eigentlich jetzt erst so richtig, was in ihm steckt, auch bei Hannover, was er eben in Lautern schon gezeigt hatte. Und deine These zu den XG oder den Expected Goals, gestern wurde die nochmal bestätigt. Expected Goals gegen Kiel 4,4 zu 0,6. Also das ist schon ein Wert, der dann auch klar macht, wie chancenlos Kiel eigentlich in dieser Partie letztendlich war. Und ja, die Transfers im Winter, das ist auf jeden Fall eine klare Ansage. Das Interessante ist ja, dass Vereine wie Hannover härter sind. Wir sind komplett da raus, lautern inzwischen so ein bisschen, auch Schalke jetzt neu. Das sind ja die Vereine, die wirklich investiert haben, um aufzusteigen. Und wenn wir mal rasch durchzählen, dann stellen wir fest, na, sie werden es nicht alle schaffen. Das heißt, bei denen, wo es schief geht, da wird es spannend zu sein, wie die Perspektive über die Saison hinaus geht. Und Hannover ist da so ein Verein. Wenn das nicht klappt, bin ich sehr gespannt, wie es in diesem Sommer bei Hannover dann weitergeht. Jetzt nicht finanziell, dass es zusammenbricht, sondern kommt der nächste Turnaround, weil das, wir erinnern uns, 3-Jahresplan mit Leiteln und dann steigen wir auf. Das wurde alles über den Haufen geworfen und die letzte Rückrunde. Und jetzt wurde ja im Grunde unfreiwillig natürlich der sportliche Leiter da getauscht. Aber ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, sollte es nochmal in die andere Richtung gehen, dass Jörg Schmatke sehr viel Geduld beweisen wird. Denn ich glaube nicht, dass er gekommen ist, um in der 2. Liga dort mit Hannover dann im Sommer nochmal dort zu versuchen und dann im Winter nochmal und so weiter. Also so wie Hannover die letzten Jahre performt hat, wird Jörg Schmatke das nicht lange mitmachen. Prophezeie ich. Denn er ist ja auch jemand, der gerne mal dazu neigt, die Sachen hinzuwerfen. Das sollten wir vielleicht an der Stelle nicht vergessen.
Ja, ich bin mal gespannt, weil man muss ehrlich gesagt auch sagen, also trotz allem und trotz der Offensive, die Hannover auch gefahren hat, trotzdem muss man ja sagen, es war von Anfang an klar, dass es eben auch eine Umbruchssaison wird. Das ist eine Leier, die fahre ich hier in Bielefeld auch immer wieder. Wie sinnvoll es ist, ein Kader, der zu 90 Prozent auf einen Trainer zugeschnitten ist und auf das, was einen Trainer spielen lassen will, zu diesem Zeitpunkt jetzt, wo du eben transvertechnisch auch nichts mehr machen kannst, dann zu sagen, wir gehen den Weg nicht weiter. Also das ist meine feste Überzeugung, warum das in Bielefeld absolut keinen Sinn machen würde, mit Kniat nicht mehr als Trainer zu haben, weil wenn man das so hört, kommen 60% der Spieler einfach wegen mit Kniat und mit der Art und Weise, wie er sie überzeugt. Ist eben immer so ein bisschen die Frage, wie sinnvoll das ist. Klar, ihr habt jetzt gerade Xtreme Wert angepackt, da wäre Hannover übrigens auch laut FODMOP auf Platz 1, gefolgt von Paderborn, Elbersberg, Schalke, also auch sehr interessant.
Übrigens bei Übersitz Pass Quote übrigens auch Platz 1.
Komisch, gefolgt von Magdeburg, komisch. Führt übrigens auch da auf Platz 18. Ich dachte, ich sag's nur nochmal.
Wo denn nicht? Das wären die interessanteren Fakten.
Jetzt wird's langsam gemeint.
Ich sag nur, was am Tisch steht. Da übrigens Fortuna Düsseldorf auf Platz 14. Ich sag's nur, ich glaube, dass...
Ja, ja, das entspricht ja dem Tabellenplatz, wie sie so gesehen.
Aber gut, das hätten wir dann auch geklärt. Nee, aber also generell, ich muss auch einfach sagen, vielleicht ist es die Nähe auch, aber keine Ahnung. Ich würde es im Jahr Anova auch mal wieder gönnen, Bundesliga zu spielen. Man weiß nie, was passiert. Wie gesagt, wir müssen gerade bei 96 auch immer auf die besondere Konstellation im Verein schauen. Es ist eine ewige Leier, aber per se, ganz ehrlich, Niedersachsen-Stadion auch immer wieder ein Besuch wert, da direkt am Marschsee.
Ich finde es…
Also im Januar war es Schweine kalt.
Aber wo war es nicht Schweine kalt im Januar, ich bin ganz ehrlich, warm fand ich es jetzt bei euch auch nicht. Und das trotz Plusgrade. Also ich sage es, wie es ist.
Also in Marbella war es sehr warm.
Aber ich würde sonst sagen, nächste Spiele, ausschließlich bei der Hertha, sehr interessant. Und dann zu Hause gegen Dresden. Das ist eine dieser, also das sind zwei sehr interessante Partien, weil einmal willst du Hertha natürlich tabellarisch jetzt von dir weghalten. Das ist klar. Und Dresden ist gerade jemand, der gerade vor allem Vereine von da oben, die können dich schon ganz gut ärgern, weil sie da eben sich auch, wir haben es eben schon besprochen und es wurde in der letzten Folge auch schon besprochen, sie haben dich schon weiterentwickelt, was glaube ich manche auch in der Winterpause so nicht erwartet haben. Also da muss man auch sagen, Respekt da nochmal nach Dresden. Aber ich würde sagen, wir kommen jetzt mal schneller zum Spiel. Ich habe hier schon wieder alle meine Zeitvorgaben irgendwie getoppt. Das war natürlich niemandem klar, außer mir selber. Wir schauen noch ganz kurz auf den VfL Bochum, denn das ist ein Verein ähnlich, wie wir das eben bei Paderborn hatten. Es ist vielleicht nicht auf dem ersten Grund ersichtlich, warum wir darüber jetzt sprechen, aber man muss einfach sagen, von da, wo der VfL Bochum kommt, sie stehen jetzt auf Platz 8. Sie haben 27 Punkte, 30 zu 27 Tore, 7 Siege, 6 Unentschieden, 8 Niederlagen. Sie sind auf Platz 7 der Formtabelle. Also ganz interessant, ein Platz über dem SC Paderborn. Es war zwar nur ein Sieg, glaube ich, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht auch schon wieder vertan habe. Genau, ein Sieg, 3 Unentschieden bzw. 4 Unentschieden, wenn man noch quasi davor guckt. Man muss aber eben sagen, man ist seit fast 9 Spielen nun ungeschlagen, was unter Uwe Rößler durchaus eine positive Bilanz weiterhin ist. Man hat u.a. eben gegen Schalke 04 gewonnen, dieses, ich möchte sagen, Ruhr-Pott-Duell. Und jetzt hat man eben in der Winterpause mit Olsen von Renners FC, das ist ein Rechtsverteidiger-Verstärker, Kalle Marschall von West Ham per Leier als Mittelstürmer und Ragnemärk ist ein Linksverteidiger. Also auch da hat man relativ klar Positionen festgestellt, wo es eben nicht ging, weil gerade das Offensivspiel, das haben wir so ein bisschen zur Hinrunde, es war schon ein sehr eindimensionales Spiel, was Bochum eben hatte. Michi, ich fange mal kurz bei dir nochmal an. Klar, Bochum spielt weiterhin, glaube ich, nicht die Sterne vom Himmel und ist als Bundesliga-Abschleiger natürlich, hängt immer noch so ein bisschen seinen Erwartungen vielleicht hier und da hinterher, aber per se muss man sagen, es ist schon beachtlich, was Uwe Rösler da beim VfL geschafft hat.
Ja, es ist vor allem beachtlich, wenn man denn die Zeit vor Uwe Rösler gesehen hat, wenn man auch gesehen hat, was er danach gemacht hat. Er hat erst mal sehr oft die Jugend gesetzt. Das war auch ein sehr mutiger Schritt. Jetzt ist er gar nicht mehr so jugendgeprägt, wie man sich die Startelf im Wochenende angeschaut hat. Also er hat vielleicht auch wieder ein bisschen auf Stabilität gesetzt, weil die Jugend das vielleicht auch nicht über 20, 25 Spiele in Folge leisten kann. Aber natürlich haben sie auch in der Rückrunde jetzt gegen fast nur Spitzen-Teams gespielt. Also wenn man sich jetzt mal anschaut, sie haben am 18. Spieltag Darmstadt 3-3, Elbersberg 1-1, Schalke gewonnen. Und jetzt kann jetzt Preußen Münster dann kein Spitzen-Team mehr, nur 1 zu 1. Das kommt auch dazu. Andererseits hat Uwe Rösler nach diesem Spiel gegen Preußen Münster jetzt dann auch gesagt, dass es Mitte gegen den Ball die beste Aussatzleistung seit ich hier bin, Zitat, war. Und man habe unheimlichen Mut bewiesen. Und es sei eigentlich eine Sensation, dass man mehr Ballbesitz als Preußen Münster habe. Und er hat vorhin Expected Goals über 2 gesprochen. Es waren dann 1,83. Also je nach Modell wahrscheinlich hat er wieder das DFL-Modell gesehen, das wieder deutlich höher liegt, warum auch immer. Aber 15 Schüsse, 7 Torschüsse, also das ist alles sehr stabil. Das hat halt nicht zum Sieg gereicht, aber davor hat man umgeschlagen gegen die Spitzenmannschaften der Liga. Insofern nach allem, was am Anfang war, ist das vollkommen okay. Und wenn man weiß, wie schwer es Mannschaften erwischen kann, nach einem Jahr in der Bundesliga, das sieht man gerade auch bei Heustern Kiel, dann ist der Vorfeld Buchum da gerade auf einem guten Weg, eine solide Übergangs-Saison zu spielen. Natürlich wird irgendwann das Ziel auch wieder mehr sein, aber in dieser Saison ging es darum, erst mal diesen Worst-Case zu vermeiden, der am Anfang ja drohte. Und jetzt ist man da wirklich einfach weit und auf einem guten Weg. Wenn der Trainer jetzt zufrieden ist mit der Entwicklung seiner Mannschaft, nimmt er auch mal ein 1-1 wahrscheinlich mit. Und dann werden sie vermutlich da unten auch nicht mehr reinrutschen. Weil es ja einfach auch, das habe ich schon mal gesagt, zu gut sind im Vergleich zu den Mannschaften, die da unten mitspielen.
Ja, finde ich ein guter Punkt. Ich fand ganz gut, dass, wenn ich mich jetzt auch nicht komplett täusche, man eben zwar eine Laie eben auch geholt hat eben im Winter, aber jetzt auch endlich mal, ich sage mal, Verpflichtungen, die über eine Halbserie hinausgehen. Das war ja so ein bisschen der Kritikpunkt, den man, den glaube ich auch Fans eben hatten, dass es so Ticken zu viel Laispieler vielleicht sind, wo du halt eben nicht weißt, okay, es ist ja alles schön und gut, dass wir uns sortieren sollen und junge Spieler und dies, das. Aber was bringt uns das, wenn im Sommer zu 50 Prozent alle wieder weg sind, so ungefähr, das muss man ja auch sagen, dann einfach Ruhbrecht und Co. Das ist ja auch immer die Frage, klar, mit Karlem Marschall hast du eben genau einen Spieler, der eben per Laie kommt, aber eben Olsen hat man eben von den Renders Mitablöse geholt und gerade davon nicht. Also seinem ersten Spiel in Münster, der hat schon gezeigt, was er da... Ich glaube, es ist eine sehr gute Idee, dass man das auf der rechten Seite bringen kann, muss ich sagen. Der hat dann nochmal neue Tiefe angeboten, einfach über die Außen. Und klar, ihr habt es eben schon angesprochen, Marschall eben, ja, nichts gegen Philipp Hoffmann, aber das war eben, da lag vielleicht auch, also erstens natürlich, ihr habt das angesprochen, die Jugendspieler, auf die man viel, ja, Last vielleicht auch sogar abgewälzt hat. Und dann halt irgendwie eben Philipp Hoffmann, der den natürlich auch immer wieder deine Tore macht, aber vielleicht jetzt auch nicht für immer die Lösung ist. Also da muss ich sagen, bietet Karl Marschall, ich finde, der ist jetzt auch nicht so der klassischste Mittelstürmer, wie gesagt, sondern der bringt echt, echt gut was mit. Das macht schon Spaß, dem da irgendwie vorne auch zuzusehen. Und das ist, glaube ich, genau das, was Bochum vorne einfach als kreativer Punkt eben auch gefehlt hat und was eben Fans auch, also ich weiß, da waren auch Leute gerade nach unserem Hinrundenrückblick auch anderer Meinung, aber das, was ich so eben von Bochum an eben auch gelesen habe, auch im 1848-Block war schon, dass Karl Marshall eben jetzt das mitbringt, was man vorher nicht hatte. Trotzdem muss man eben sagen, dieses Spiel gegen Münster, das musst du eigentlich verlieren, weil ich habe es eben schon mal gesagt, kein Team ist gerade so formschwach wie der SCP. Da war was drin und eigentlich ist es schon komplett unnötig, dass du in dieser Partie viel zu hoch stehst und dann kassierst du dieses 1-0. Also da steht die letzte Abwehrreihe von Bochum enorm hoch. Und wenn du halt sagst, wir nehmen mehr Ball als Münster, dann musst du dich halt darauf einstellen, dass Münster auf Konter geht. Und dann so offen zu stehen, ist natürlich nicht das Beste. Aber per se kann man glaube ich sagen.
War aber ein schöner Pass für Jotendrix, dem Ex-Fortuna und dem Geburtstagskind.
Ja, es war ein wunderschöner Pass. Also hat auf beiden Seiten natürlich Probleme auch offenbart, ehrlich gesagt dieses Spiel. Aber ich sehe trotzdem, also ich habe einfach die Hoffnung, no Offens an Bochum, aber diese Spiele anzugucken, waren halt auch wirklich einfach nicht schön. So, also weder war das, ich war bei Bielefeld gegen Bochum im Stadion, das war nicht schön. Das haben sie am Ende durch individuelle Klasse gewonnen, weil sonst gerne das Spiel auch einfach, weil beide Mannschaften so furchtbar schlecht waren, auch einfach 0-0 ausgehen. Beim Spiel gegen Hannover wissen sie selber nicht, wie die nicht verloren haben. Und jetzt hast du aber klar die ganzen Unentschieden. Es ist aber trotzdem, du verlierst halt nicht. So und das ist eben der positive Punkt. Du verlierst wenigstens keine Punkte nach unten, weil du Spiele verlierst. Das klingt total bescheuert und total simpel. Aber es ist gerade das, was dich eben einfach am Leben erhält und dich aus dieser direkten, direkten, wohlgemerkt Abschiedsgefahr raushält. Weil es also 27 Punkte, wir haben eben gesagt, so ganz wissen wir nicht, wo wir den Cut ansetzen können. Aber das ist schon mal eine gute Entwicklung. Thorsten, gerne.
Ja, ich wollte noch kurz was sagen und zwar, also zum einen, es war tatsächlich auch nur eine Niederlage unter Uwe Rösler. Und das ist natürlich wirklich der Wendepunkt der Saison. Ich war hier beim letzten Spiel sozusagen vor Uwe Rösler im Stadion. Das war die vorletzte Partie von Daniel Thun, hat man vielleicht mitgekriegt, war ein großes Endspiel etc. Und da lag wirklich ein großer Mehltau über dem ganzen VfL Bochum in der Zeit. Und ja, der wurde so ein bisschen durch Uwe Rösler weggepustet. Da war glaube ich dieses erste Spiel von ihm gegen Hertha, das war ganz, ganz wichtig. 3 zu 2 Sieg. Und ich glaube, dann sind ihm halt alle gefolgt. Kann man jetzt sehen, wie man will von– ich nenne es jetzt mal den Spökes, den er da vor den Fans immer macht mit kurzer Hose und so. Das sind manchmal vielleicht auch nette Geschichten. Für mich ist immer ein bisschen drüber, aber sei es drum. Ich kann aus der Erfahrung– Uwe Rösler war ja auch ein Düsseldorftrainer– kann ich sagen, ich habe immer das Gefühl gehabt, dass das eine Art ist, die sich relativ schnell verbraucht. Ich will es jetzt aber gar nicht zu sehr negativ für die Bochum-Fans sehen. Was damals wirklich ein großer Punkt war, als er nach Funkel kam, es schien wie eine taktische Revolution. Bei allem Respekt vor Friedhelm Funkel, aber er ist natürlich jetzt eher jemand, der über die Köpfe der Spieler kommt. Und da hat dann Rösler gerade, was das betrifft, einige Dinge eingeführt. Ich habe aber nicht das Gefühl, dass er bei Bochum so radikal Dinge verändert hat, sondern dass er tatsächlich die Köpfe der Spieler so ein bisschen da gut frei bekommen hat. Und ja, du hast schon über die Transfers gesprochen. Ich wollte noch einen billigen Witz machen, und zwar der Marschallplan hilft beim Wiederaufbau, ja. Das ist für die Geschichtsfreude hier. Und ich wollte aber noch eine Ergänzung machen. Also man hat natürlich auch vor allem Oliver Olsen geholt, als Ersatz für Felix Paszlak, der nämlich jetzt gegangen ist, zur Hibernian FC, sodass man da die Außenverteidigung so ein bisschen besser besetzen musste. Und ich wollte natürlich noch aus alter Verbundenheit Marcel Sobotka erwähnen, der als vereinsloser Spieler hat keinen neuen Vertrag letzten Sommer in Düsseldorf bekommen, jetzt beim VfL Bochum unter Vertrag ist. Und man kennt sich natürlich auch aus den Düsseldorfer Zeiten, sodass er da, ja ich sag mal als ein routinierter, jetzt nicht als Stammspieler, ist er bisher nicht, sondern eher so als ein routinierter Kaderspieler mit reingenommen wurde und da Masel Sobotka wirklich viele Freunde in Düsseldorf hat. Liebe Curissa an dieser Stelle. Wird ein bisschen schwer, wenn er auf dem Platz stehen dürfte. Er ist halt wirklich ein Spieler, der hier 10 Jahre gespielt hat. Das ist dann nicht schön, wenn Bochum Ende des Monats in drei Wochen dann zu uns kommt, sollte Masel Sobotka da im blauen Trikot sein. Das fühlt sich ein bisschen falscher.
Ja, das kann ich nachvollziehen. Ich würde sonst sagen, die nächsten beiden Spiele von VfW Bochum, das sind zwei Heimspiele. Und zwar gegen den SC Paderborn und den 1. FC Nürnberg. Also ja, auch eigentlich ganz spannend, weil ich glaube, also über Nürnberg haben wir heute gar nicht gesprochen, aber da auch, also im direkten Sinne, sage ich mal, auch da durchaus ja Potenzial da viel zu bereden beim 1. FCN. Auch was so, ja, Weggang von großen Persönlichkeiten betrifft, könnte man sagen. Sonst würde ich aber sagen, wir haben es nach, ich kann ja mal transparent sein, vorm Schlusswort wirklich, als hätte uns jemand da wirklich noch alles in die Wege geworfen. Von daher wundert euch nicht, wenn es hier auch etwas abgehackt ist im Schnitt hinterher. Wir haben es versucht, so best wie möglich zu lösen. Vielen, vielen Dank an der Stelle an Michi und Thorsten für euer Durchhaltevermögen, eure Geduld hier erst mal, das schon mal zu bewilligen generell. Und sonst kann ich sagen, ich würde sagen, bevor hier die Technik uns noch einen Strich durch die Rechnung macht, ich bin heute einfach mal richtig stumpf. Und sage an der Stelle vielen, vielen Dank an Michi Fischer für das kurzfristige Einspringen. Es ist immer wieder eine Freude mit dir. Danke, Michi.
Sehr gerne. Geduld und Durchhaltevermögen sind wichtige Attribute als Reporter bei der Spielverhandlung aus Fürth. Danke.
Und dann lieben Dank auch an Thorsten für dein Debüt hier.
Ja, vielen, lieben Dank für die Einladung. Das hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Und dann sehen wir uns in zwei Wochen wieder. Macht's gut. Tschüss. Tschüss. Das war der Rasenfunk.
Von Ihnen unterstützt.
Herzlichen Dank. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.